I just came back from dinner at a
friend's place looking forward to
hitting my Korean again had a quite a
productive day today probably got in
about three and a half four hours three
hours or so up reading and then another
45 minutes or so while working out and
I'm gonna show you a bit of that but I
just want to kind of reflect a bit on
the relationship between working out
like exercising physically and language
learning just as in working out
physically you know you don't get fit
from one you know stint in the gym or
from exercising every now and again you
actually have to do it regularly another
similarity and this is true of language
learning you have to do it regularly
another similarity is that just as in
exercising you have like aerobic
exercises anaerobic exercises like you
know long-distance building up your
aerobic capacity short-distance
like sprinting to build up your
explosive quick muscle capability
strength exercises and similarly in
language learning I find that it's good
to very listening to sort of basic
patterns simple things to vary that with
listening to more interesting content
where you are acquiring new vocabulary
and and getting more engrossed into the
subject matter it's important to marry
the two so I'm going to show that a bit
in in this little snippet that I did
downstairs where we have where I have my
exercise equipment and that'll be it for
day 11 I should point out that I had a
chat on Friday and discovered lots of
gaps in my check so I'm putting more
effort into getting you know working on
something not check sorry my Korean
working some of the basic patterns but
I'm also not neglecting building out my
my vocabulary and what everyday eleven
ninety days she's I'm already past the
10% mark this is one way of getting
myself into the picture I'm taking a
picture of myself in the mirror
down here on in my gym which is actually
not a gym I don't use this machine very
much we bought it about 15 20 years ago
but more than anything else
I used these little items here dumbbell
little BOSU that I stand on when I lift
weights I got a medicine ball which I
can do ab exercises on I the other day I
showed you with that strap that I hang
it kind of hook in a door well or the
door closed the door on it and do a
whole bunch of exercises but I always do
this while listening and here you have
you can just make it out is you know my
mp3 player my old iPod in a dock and I
can listen to this typically easier
stuff is good that's my wife playing
plan on the background this by the way
is my Nordic track which I was just on
today had a good you know work good 20
25 minutes 20 minutes today I guess but
that stuff that's good to listen to is
when you're good then you can listen to
really interesting content like I used
to listen to my Russian and checked on
here but at my level in Korea and I
prefer to stay with simple simple stuff
and today I had a good I would say three
hours reading some basic sort of
repeating the basic patterns of the
language and I always like to combine
the sort of interesting content like I'm
fighting my way through editorials from
the Traulsen Hill Buju a boy a Korean
newspaper which keeps my interest level
up but at the same time today I was good
three hours reading through basic
patterns in the language of this
particular book for anyone who speaks
Japanese and wants to learn Korean it's
very good because it just goes over all
the basic patterns of the language I
also didn't do it so much today but I
have spent some time this week on this
book which I mentioned continuing Korean
I went through about half of a sea meal
today just reading through reading
through reading through and the other
day I went through the colloquial Korean
it's just a matter of exposing myself to
the basic pattern hoping that eventually
they
they start to stick and I start to
notice them when I listen but I think
another point that I'm trying to show
here is that you know you got to invest
in the tools for language learning
invest in you know mp3 player and
earphones but also in some exercise
stuff it depends I guess on how much
room you have in your home but if you
have a place to work out and if you get
stuff that that you can kind of you know
you can't focus on it's gotta be like
60% you're tuned in 40% you're tuned out
but so you're working out guess that the
Drennen and I don't know what other
chemical stuff is rushing around in your
body that's good for you and you're
spending that time also listening to
language and I think that's a very
powerful combination
and with that we'll look at the we'll
look at the sunset here in Vancouver out
in the ocean there and I hope that's
helpful to you bye for now